From NPR, this is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. When Jessica Langamon was 12, she had a favorite TV show. This is a little embarrassing to admit, but I was crazy about Star Trek. Space, the final frontier. One day, several of the actors came to my hometown. So I begged my mother to take me, and I walked up to a table, and there was Leonard Nimoy. Stand by to Bimma. It was Mr. Spock.
来自NPR，这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。杰西卡·兰加蒙12岁时，有一个她最喜欢的电视节目。说出来可能有点尴尬，但我当时对《星际迷航》着迷得不行。太空，最后的边疆。一天，剧中的几位演员来到了我的家乡。于是我恳求母亲带我去，我走到一张桌子前，莱昂纳德·尼莫伊就在那里。准备好对接。那是史波克先生。
The cerebral star of the show always calm, ever logical. For years, Jessica had felt a deep kinship with Spock, and now here he was, right in front of her. And of course I knew every angle of his face, I knew the curve of his ears, I knew everything about him or so I felt. And when I put my notebook down for him to autograph, he looked at me with complete blank non-recognition. And I was so confused in that moment. I knew him so well, but he did not know me.
这位剧中的智力担当总是那么冷静，永远讲逻辑。多年来，杰西卡一直对史波克有一种深厚的亲近感，而现在他就站在她眼前。当然，我熟悉他脸上的每一个角度，我熟悉他耳朵的轮廓，我了解关于他的一切——或者说我是这么觉得的。当我把笔记本放下让他签名时，他茫然地看着我，完全没有认出我。那一刻我感到非常困惑。我对他如此了解，但他却不认识我。
Danny Martinez understands what it's like to feel a deep connection to someone who doesn't know you. I'd tell you I don't get no respect for anyone, you know? Oh my God. I've never expected all. Rodney Dangerfield. I mean, the last week my wife, she's signing up for a bridge club. I jump off next Tuesday.
丹尼·马丁内斯懂那种对一个不认识你的人产生深厚连接是什么感觉。我会告诉你，我根本不受任何人尊重，你知道吗？哦，天哪。我从未有过期待。罗德尼·丹杰菲尔德。我是说，上周我老婆，她报名参加了一个桥牌俱乐部。我下周二就跳楼。
I remember when Rodney Dangerfield died, I cried, and like I had lost my grandfather, and no one could understand why I would care so much. Eric Palileo says his connection with a singer named Anoni was transformational. He still remembers the moment he first heard her song, Ghost. He was 15 at his home in Texas. All of a sudden, I remember just sitting on the couch and like not really knowing even how to react. It was so overwhelming. The ordinary became extraordinary. It's just like a dramatic shift in the way that you're seeing the world and that couch
我记得罗德尼·丹杰菲尔德去世时，我哭了，就像失去了祖父一样，没有人能理解为什么我在乎那么多。埃里克·帕利莱奥说他与一位名叫安诺尼的歌手的连接具有变革意义。他依然记得自己第一次听到她的歌《Ghost》时的情景。当时他15岁，在德克萨斯州的家中。突然之间，我记得自己只是坐在沙发上，甚至不知道该如何反应。那太震撼了。平凡变得非凡。就像你看世界的方式发生了戏剧性的转变，而那张沙发
wasn't just the couch and that room just wasn't just a room in this house. Actually had a meaning to it now. Psychologists sometimes refer to such emotional connections as parasocial relationships, one-way relationships. In some ways, they are akin to the imaginary friends that children have. As we grow up, we are told to set such relationships aside, to tuck our stuffed animals away in a closet. Clinging to imaginary companions can suggest that you are lonely or maladjusted.
不只是一张沙发，那个房间也不只是房子里的一个房间。它现在确实有了意义。心理学家有时将这种情感连接称为准社会关系，即单向关系。在某种程度上，它们类似于小孩子们拥有的想象中的朋友。随着我们长大，我们被告知要抛开这些关系，把毛绒玩具塞进壁橱里。执着于想象中的同伴可能暗示你很孤独或适应不良。
But what if there is more to these relationships than we realize? This week on Hidden Brain, the thin line between the imaginary and the real. Growing up, Megan Lincoln was different from other kids. She tried to hide it, but her secret always came out. Like when her teacher would make everyone go around the room, reading aloud from a book. And then you would read as much as you wanted, and then you would say done, and then you would say someone else's name, and then they would pick up from there. So that would be the worst experience of my life because I didn't know when the person was going to be done and when my name was going to be called. So I would sit there trying to figure out how I could get out of the classroom because I couldn't read.
但是，如果这些关系比我们意识到的还要深刻呢？本周的“隐藏的大脑”，探讨想象与现实之间的纤细界限。在成长过程中，梅根·林肯与别的孩子不同。她试图隐藏这一点，但她的秘密总是会暴露。比如当老师让全班轮流站起来大声朗读一本书时。然后你可以读你想读的那么多，接着你说“读完了”，然后说出另一个人的名字，接着他们从那里继续读。所以这会成为我人生中最糟糕的经历，因为我不知道那个人什么时候能读完，什么时候会点到我的名字。所以我就会坐在那里，想方设法怎么能逃出教室，因为我不会认字。
It made her feel ashamed. She had walkarounds. She would watch the movie instead of doing the reading or choose the book that had the most pictures or simply figure out a way to get out of the classroom. That was her best strategy. Just try to escape. When all the other kids were exchanging their homework for another student to grade, she would raise her hand and say she had to go to the bathroom. Yeah, I would stay there forever. I would slowly walk to the bathroom, and then I would hang out there, watch my hands a lot, look in the mirror, just do whatever I could to waste time. But one teacher, Ms. Doyle, noticed Meghan getting frustrated when she tried to read.
这让她感到羞耻。她有应对的办法。她会看电影而不是去阅读，或者选择图片最多的书，或者干脆想办法离开教室。那是她最好的策略。只想逃跑。当其他所有孩子们在互相交换家庭作业给另一个同学打分时，她会举手说她必须去洗手间。是的，我会一直在那待着。我会慢慢走到洗手间，然后在那里晃悠，拼命洗手，照镜子，只要能消磨时间什么都做。但有一位老师，多伊尔女士，注意到梅根在尝试阅读时变得很沮丧。
And so one day she pulled me aside and we were just talking about life and talking about how I was not dumb, really defining dyslexia for me and then telling me that there were other people in the world who were dyslexic, just like me. And you know, she told me Winston Churchill, she told me Walt Disney, she told me Albert Einstein and Tom Cruise and told me share. and Tom Cruise, and told me Cher.
所以有一天她把我拉到一边，我们只是聊了聊生活，谈论我并不是笨，真正为我定义了什么是读写困难，然后告诉我世界上还有其他人也患有读写困难，就像我一样。你知道的，她告诉我温斯顿·丘吉尔，她告诉我沃尔特·迪斯尼，她告诉我阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦和汤姆·克鲁斯，还有雪儿。
Ladies and gentlemen, Sunny and Cher. Something clicked in Meghan's imagination. Cher started popping up in my head all the time. She didn't know why. I mean, I loved Sunny and Cher. I loved their variety show. They were funny. I have a photograph going. So you know the only thing wrong with your photographic mind. What's that? It never developed. If you look at share and she goes on stage she's not what I'm quote yourotypical normal person.
女士们先生们，索尼和雪儿。梅根的想象力中有什么东西被触动了。雪儿开始一直蹦进我的脑海里。她不知道为什么。我是说，我喜欢索尼和雪儿。我喜欢他们的综艺节目。他们很搞笑。我有张照片正在……所以你知道你的摄影记忆唯一不对劲的地方是什么。是什么？它从来没冲洗出来。如果你看雪儿，她上台时她不是我所说的典型的正常人。
Winner is Sharon Munsai. She doesn't care if she's wearing this weird old black outfit with like, you know, where her thighs are showing and she's got these crazy tights on. She doesn't care what people think about her. I want to thank my mom because when I was really young, my mom said, you're not going to be the smartest, you're not going to be the prettiest, you're not going to be the most talented, but you're going to be special. And I think as a young girl,
赢家是沙伦·蒙赛。她才不在乎自己是不是穿着这套怪异的旧黑色衣服，比如你知道的，大腿都露出来了，还穿着那种疯狂的紧腿裤。她才不在乎别人怎么看她。我要感谢我的妈妈，因为当我非常小的时候，我妈妈说，你不会是最聪明的，你不会是最漂亮的，你不会是最有才华的，但你会是特别的。我想作为一个年轻女孩，
not feeling confident of who I was, having someone who was so strong, really made me feel that, why should I care what people are saying about me in the classroom? One day, the share in her mind that something she hadn't done before. She talked to Megan. It was her voice.
对真实的自己没有信心，身边有一个如此坚强的人，真的让我觉得，凭什么我在教室里要在乎别人对我说什么？有一天，她脑海里的那个雪儿做了一件她以前没做过的事。她跟梅根说话了。那是她的声音。
It was her recognizable share voice. She was as real to me as my friend next to me. I couldn't see her. I could just hear her. And it was real. It was her. After this happened a few times, Megan got used to it. She said, okay, it's Cher. She's talking to me.
那是她标志性的雪儿的声音。她对我的真实程度就像我身边的朋友一样。我看不到她。我只能听到她。那是真的。就是她。在发生过几次之后，梅根习惯了。她说，好吧，是雪儿。她在跟我说话。
She would only talk to me when I was feeling dumb or insecure. And if I was feeling like insecure for something that was not school or reading or writing specifics, her voice wouldn't appear. Now, when Megan's anxieties were in, Sherwood offered encouragement. The one thing I always remembered her saying to me is, if you think you are dumb, then you think I am dumb. And I am not dumb.
她只在我感觉自己很笨或没有安全感的时候跟我说话。如果是因为学校、阅读或写作的具体事情之外的原因让我感到没有安全感，她的声音就不会出现。现在，当梅根的焦虑出现时，雪儿会给予鼓励。我一直记得她对我说的一件事是，如果你觉得自己很笨，那你就是觉得我很笨。而我并不笨。
And then she would tell me to go back to reading or go back to trying to write something. And when she tried to hide out in the bathroom, share wouldn't let her. I remember her telling me that it was smelly in the bathroom. Why are you sitting in a smelly bathroom? She's like, you're better than this. Go back and take that test.
然后她会叫我回去阅读，或者回去尝试写点东西。当她试图躲在洗手间里时，雪儿不让她这么做。我记得她告诉我洗手间里很难闻。你为什么坐在一个臭气熏天的洗手间里？她就像是在说，你比这更好。回去把那个测试考了。
Confront the test, it would be much better than sitting here in this smelly bathroom. And I would take my deep breath and I would walk out and I would smile, you know, and I'd probably curse her out a little bit and I go back into that classroom and take that test. I never felt dumb after that. After her secret friend helped her for a few years, Megan started to feel more confident, and that's when she's voice disappeared. It's kind of like Mary Poppins. The kids no longer needed her.
面对考试，可比坐在这个臭气熏天的洗手间里强多了。然后我会深吸一口气，走出去，你知道的，脸上带着微笑，我可能还会稍微在心里骂她几句，然后回到那个教室去参加测试。在那之后我再也没有觉得自己笨过。在她的秘密朋友帮助了她几年之后，梅根开始变得更加自信，也就是在这个时候，雪儿的声音消失了。这有点像玛丽·波平斯。孩子们不再需要她了。
Something in my head just told me I didn't need her and she left. Maybe she went to someone their person's head who needed her, I don't know. Today, Megan has multiple degrees, a successful career. She's figured out how to manage her dyslexia. But she's been reluctant to tell people how share helped her. It sounds kind of strange. You know, who has in her voice that sounds like some celebrity? Only crazy, he's too.
我脑子里的某个东西只是告诉我我不再需要她了，然后她就离开了。也许她去了某个需要她的人的脑子里，我不知道。如今，梅根拥有多个学位，事业有成。她已经找到了如何应对读写困难的方法。但她一直不愿告诉别人雪儿是如何帮助她的。这听起来有点奇怪。你知道的，谁的脑海里会有听起来像某个名人的声音？只有疯子才会。
I just tell people I love her. I got you, babe. I got you, babe. I got you, babe. I got you, babe. They say I love you. Megan misses the comfort of Sher's voice. Every now and then, she tries to recreate it.
我只告诉别人我爱她。我罩着你，宝贝。我罩着你，宝贝。我罩着你，宝贝。我罩着你，宝贝。他们说我爱你。梅根怀念雪儿声音带来的慰藉。每隔一段时间，她就会试图重现它。
But it's me making her voice. It's different. You know what I'm saying? It wasn't in her voice. Yes, it wasn't myself. I knew it really wasn't her. But I also didn't feel I was wise enough to be as wise as she was to me. The voices we hear, the secret friends we have, the often don't seem like mere extensions of ourselves.
但那是我在模仿她的声音。这不一样。你知道我在说什么吗？那不是她的声音。是的，那不是我自己。我知道那真的不是她。但我也觉得自己没有那么大智慧，无法像她对那样我一样充满智慧。我们听到的声音，我们拥有的秘密朋友，通常看起来并不像是我们自己的单纯延伸。
Megan's head share seemed to be braver than she was, wiser than she was. The share in Megan's head, new things, than Megan didn't know. How is this possible? How can one part of the mind know something that another part of the same mind does not know? When we come back, we explore this question in another domain. We look at people who hear not the voice of a singer or a celebrity, but the voice of something much bigger. I mean fundamentally the story of God was a story about the human imagination, the human capacity to take seriously the sense that the world that we see it before us is not all there is
梅根脑海里的雪儿似乎比她更勇敢，比她更睿智。梅根脑海里的雪儿知道一些梅根不知道的事情。这怎么可能？为什么心灵的一部分能知道同一心灵的另一部分不知道的事情？当我们回来时，我们将在另一个领域探讨这个问题。我们来看看那些听到的不是歌手或名人的声音，而是某种更伟大的东西的声音的人。我的意思是，从根本上说，上帝的故事是关于人类想象力的故事，是关于人类认真对待这样一种观念的能力，即我们眼前看到的这个世界并不是世界的全部。
of the world. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. As a young person, Tanya Lerman did not believe in God. I couldn't understand how people could believe in an omnipotent, omniscient maker who would allow people to suffer so much. It seemed logically incoherent to me. She was known among her peers as an atheist. She even wrote about it in an op-ed for her school newspaper. Her friends came up with their own version of the headline. The tagline among my friends was that Lurperson does not believe in God.
这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。年轻时，塔尼娅·勒曼不相信上帝。我不明白人们怎么能相信一个允许人类遭受如此多苦难的全能、全知的造物主。这在我看来逻辑上不通。她在同龄人中是个出了名的无神论者。她甚至在学校校报的专栏文章中写过这一点。她的朋友们还想出了他们自己版本的标题。我朋友间流传的标签是“勒曼本人不相信上帝”。
Emma is called Lurperson because I was a feminist and Lurman anyway. That was the way my friends referred to me. Tanya's parents were also actively questioning the idea of religious faith. They had grown up in devout homes. Her mother's father was a Baptist minister. Her father's father was a Christian scientist. But her father had become a determined atheist. At one point in college, he actually ceremoniously burnt his membership card to the mother church in Boston.
埃玛被称为“勒曼本人”，因为我当时是个女权主义者，而且反正也姓勒曼。那是我的朋友们指代我的方式。塔尼娅的父母也在积极质疑宗教信仰的概念。他们成长于虔诚的家庭。她母亲的父亲是一名浸礼会牧师。她父亲的父亲是一名基督教科学派信徒。但她的父亲已经成了一个坚定的无神论者。在大学的某个阶段，他甚至在波士顿母教堂举行了隆重的仪式，烧毁了自己的会员卡。
Her mother kept going to church, but loved to read books by Sam Harris, the atheist neuroscientist. You know, my mother also was torn. It's just kind of wanted to believe, but it was. She found it logically tough. Although her dad disapproved, Tanya's mom took her to church every Sunday. Tania found herself fascinated by how smart good people could reach very different conclusions about God and religion.
她的母亲继续去教堂，但喜欢阅读无神论神经科学家萨姆·哈里斯的书。你知道的，我母亲也很纠结。这有点像是想去相信，但它。她发现这在逻辑上很难接受。尽管父亲不赞成，塔尼娅的妈妈还是每个星期天带她去教堂。塔尼娅发现自己对聪明的好人如何能对上帝和宗教得出截然不同的结论着迷不已。
And I wanted to understand more about how things became real to people. And how people came to decide that God was real, or they came to feel that the world was organized in a particular way. As Tanya grew up, she thought briefly about becoming a psychiatrist, her dad was a psychiatrist, but eventually settled on a different profession. Anthropology. If psychiatrists have a set of descriptions about what constitutes normal behavior and assess when and how much people deviate from those norms,
我想更多地了解事物是如何对人们变得真实的。以及人们是如何决定上帝是真实的，或者他们是如何感觉到世界是以特定方式组织的。随着塔尼娅长大，她曾短暂考虑过成为一名精神病医生，她父亲就是精神病医生，但最终选择了另一种职业。人类学。如果精神病医生有一套关于什么构成正常行为的描述，并评估人们何时以及在多大程度上偏离这些规范，
anthropology demands that you suspend judgment, that you try to understand people on their own terms, from the inside out, rather than from the outside in. Anthropologists are in some ways little amoebas. We're trying to ask what it feels like to live in somebody else's world. And there's an anthropologist called Clifford Gertz who said that before you judge you need to understand and that that was the kind of the moral impulse of our field. I think the people who become anthropologists want, they're curious about what it's like to walk in someone else's shoes. And I think
人类学则要求你悬置判断，试图按照人们自己的方式去理解他们，从内到外，而不是从外到内。人类学家在某些方面就像小变形虫。我们试图去感受生活在别人世界里是什么滋味。有一位名叫克利福德·格尔茨的人类学家曾说过，在你评判之前，你需要去理解，这就是我们领域的道德冲动。我认为成为人类学家的人都想要、他们很好奇穿别人的鞋走路是什么感觉。我认为
that you don't do that well if you have a pretty clear view from the outside of what that other world is like. Tanya realized she was drawn to this approach. She wanted to immerse herself deeply with people whose frames and norms were different from her own. I mean, at some point, you need to come to a kind of moral reckoning with the world that you are looking at and your sense of who you are in your own world. But I do think that when you, to the extent that you can, when you let go of who you are
如果你从外部对那个别样的世界有一个非常清晰的看法，你就做不好这一点。塔尼娅意识到自己被这种方法吸引了。她想让自己深深沉浸在那些框架和规范与她不同的人群中。我的意思是，在某个时刻，你需要对自己所审视的世界以及你在自己世界中的身份认同进行某种道德清算。但我确实认为，当你尽可能地放下自我，
and you try to become different, you see and feel things differently. In the spring of 1983, when she was 23 years old, Tanya decided to put this idea into practice. She was in England doing her PhD in anthropology. She focused her field research on a group of people who believed they could cast spells and perform magic rituals. Tania, the rationalist, was personally skeptical of these claims, but she had made a commitment to listen openly, without judgment. She attended a retreat with about 50 practitioners at a beautiful, remote, manor house.
当你试图变得不同时，你看到和感受到事物的方式就会不同。1983年春天，23岁的塔尼娅决定将这个想法付诸实践。当时她在英国攻读人类学博士学位。她将田野调查的重点放在了一群相信自己能够施咒和进行魔法仪式的人身上。理性主义者塔尼娅个人对这些说法持怀疑态度，但她承诺会以开放的心态倾听，不做评判。她和一个美丽的偏远庄园里的约50名从业者一起参加了一场静修。
The leader of the group was Gareth Knight. To Tania, he looked like Merlin, the wizard. In a, and he had this big shock of white hair and he had flowing robes. I mean, you know, this was Harry Potter line before Harry Potter. The goal of the weekend was to encounter what Gareth called contacts. He said contacts were highly evolved human beings, no longer tethered to their bodies, who could offer guidance. They were like wise, invisible people. And so he would just talk about them as if they were friends. He would, you know,
该团伙的领导者是加雷斯·奈特。在塔尼娅看来，他看起来像巫师梅林。而且他有一头蓬乱的白发，穿着飘逸的长袍。我的意思是，你知道的，这可是哈利·波特之前的哈利·波特。那个周末的目标是遇到加雷斯所说的“联络者”。他说联络者是高度进化的人类，不再受肉体束缚，能够提供指导。他们就像明智的、隐形的人。所以他谈论他们时就像谈论朋友一样。你知道的，他会
stride up and down before the group of 50 people and talk about, you know, how we're gonna do a big, ritual event. Gareth explained that he would guide them through a spiritual exercise using a mystical set of pictures, a temple, a priestess, a hermit. He lit four candles and told everyone to close their eyes. They were now aboard a ship he told them and they were going to accompany him to another world. And what this man did during the weekend was to, in effect, tell story after story about
在50人面前踱来踱去，谈论我们将如何举办一场盛大的仪式活动。加雷斯解释说，他将通过一套神秘的图片（一座神庙、一位女祭司、一位隐士）引导他们进行精神练习。他点燃了四支蜡烛，告诉所有人闭上眼睛。他们现在登上一艘船，他告诉他们，他们将陪同他前往另一个世界。这个人在那个周末所做的事情，实际上就是讲述一个又一个关于
these pictures, in a way that he wanted us to experience these pictures as if we were living in a dream, as if we were going down a river and we were all in a boat together and we would get it, we got out of the boat and we would look up and we would see a temple and there was the priestess and this is what the priestess looked like. And he wanted us to experience those stories as if they were happening. Tanya had only planned to record the experiences of the group. But as she imagined the stories along with them at that initial retreat and subsequent meetings,
这些图片的故事，他希望我们去体验这些图片，就像我们生活在梦中一样，就像我们顺流而下，我们都在同一条船上，然后我们会靠岸，我们下船，抬头看去，会看到一座神庙，那里有女祭司，这就是女祭司的样子。他希望我们去体验这些正在发生的故事。塔尼娅原本只计划记录这个群体的经历。但当她在最初的静修和随后的聚会中与他们一起想象这些故事时，
she found that her own impressions were becoming a vital source of data. Over the first three or four months, it occurred to me that my mental images were becoming sharper, that they were becoming richer. She started attending the group's weekly dream interpretation class, and she began to keep a dream diary. And my dreams were becoming vivid and dripping with symbolism. I remember having a dream at one point in which what I knew was my soul was swimming across a river in a thunderstorm to scramble up the other side on this bank of mud and I kept falling back and
她发现自己的直觉正在成为至关重要的的数据来源。在前三四个月里，我发现我的心理图像变得越来越清晰，越来越丰富。她开始参加该团伙每周的解梦课，并开始记梦日记。我的梦变得生动起来，浸透了象征意义。我记得有一次做了一个梦，在雷雨中，我知道是我的灵魂在游过一条河，在泥泞的河岸上挣扎着爬到对岸，我一直在往下掉，
then I'd go forward and I remember waking up and thinking, oh my goodness, I'm having different kinds of dreams and that was a dream about my soul. It was like the work she was doing was changing the way her own mind worked. It was changing what she saw in the world, how she experienced the world. The world felt as if it was becoming more connected. It felt like I was having these synchronicities, things would, you know, I'd walk into the green grocer and the green grocer would say something that I'd been thinking about. And so I would have these experiences and then over the course
然后我又往前走，我记得醒来时想，噢天哪，我正在做不同种类的梦，那是一个关于我灵魂的梦。这就像她正在做的工作正在改变她自己思维运作的方式。它正在改变她在世界上看到的东西，她体验世界的方式。这个世界感觉好像变得更加紧密相连了。感觉我正在经历这些共时性事件，事情会，你知道的，我会走进绿色食品杂货店，蔬菜商就会说出我一直在想的事情。所以我有这些经历，然后在整个
of the year, you know, I really saw myself change, felt myself change. When I spoke to her, Tanya thought back to another moment when the line between the real and the imaginary became blurred. It was only during her field research and she was in a train to meet Gareth Knight for the first time. She was reading a book about magic and mysticism. It was called Experience of the Inner Worlds. It was about the experience of power and this idea of a power outside of me that was present and kind of there in the world.
一年中，你知道的，我真的看到自己发生了变化，感觉自己发生了变化。当我与她交谈时，塔尼娅回想起了另一个时刻，在那一刻，现实与想象之间的界限变得模糊了。那是正当她在进行田野调查时，她正坐火车去见加雷斯·奈特。她正在读一本关于魔法和神秘主义的书。这本书叫《内心世界的体验》。它是关于力量的体验以及这种我之外的某种力量存在于世界上的观念。
It was kind of new to me. The book was esoteric and complex, and she strained her mind to understand it. On the Kabbalistic Tree of Life Framework, we see a method of philosophical classification that's able to take in the concept of both creator and the creation. This is not so evident in you. And he was talking about Tibetan this and Kabbalistic that and white light that. And I remember kind of chess trying to understand the sentences and concentrating so hard and there are people around me talking and trying to really focus on the book. Right then, she started to feel hot. I began to feel power.
这对我来说有点新奇。这本书深奥而复杂，她绞尽脑汁去理解它。在卡巴拉生命之树的框架上，我们看到了哲学分类的一种方法，它能够同时容纳创造者和创造物的概念。这在你的身上并不是那么明显。他当时在谈论西藏这个和卡巴拉那个，还有白光什么的。我记得自己一边试图理解这些句子，一边集中精力，周围有人在说话，我试图真正专注于这本书。就在那时，她开始觉得热。我开始感受到力量。
Like an electrical charge that seemed to move through me, starting at above me and moving through my body and going into the floor. And it was strong and it was vivid and I felt fantastic. I felt more alive. I felt completely alert, seemed like all of my senses were incredibly sharp. And as I was feeling this way, I'm trying to figure out what on earth was going on. And as I was feeling this way, I'm trying to figure out what on earth was going on. I looked over and there were whips of smoke coming out of my bag. A battery powered by clamsheet stored in her bag was melting.
就像一股电荷似乎在我体内移动，从我上方开始，穿过我的身体，进入地板。它是强烈的，生动的，我感觉棒极了。我感觉更有活力了。我感到完全警觉，似乎我的所有感官都极其敏锐。正当我这样感受时，我试图弄清楚这到底是怎么回事。正当我这样感受时，我试图弄清楚这到底是怎么回事。我转头一看，我的包里正冒出一缕缕烟雾。她包里装着的一个蛤壳电池正在融化。
It's like, the battery was melting and these bicycle lights. Now, there are two ways to think of this. battery was melting and these bicycle lights. Now there are two ways to think of this. You can see Tania's thoughts about power melted the battery. Or you can say, huh, interesting coincidence. But the point is, if you put yourself in a frame of mind where you expect unusual things to happen, you're more likely to see unusual things happen. The time she spent with Gareth and the others taught Tanya something very important about
就像是，电池正在融化，还有这些自行车灯。现在，有两种方式来看待这个问题。电池正在融化，还有这些自行车灯。现在，有两种方式来看待这个问题。你可以认为塔尼娅关于力量的想法融化了电池。或者你可以说，哈，有趣的巧合。但关键是，如果你让自己处于一种期望不寻常事情发生的精神状态，你更有可能看到不寻常的事情发生。她与加雷斯和其他人在一起度过的时间教会了塔尼娅关于
the imagination. It's a skill. You can improve it, make it sharper, you can practice it, and when you do, remarkable things follow. There's all kinds of things that people experience. But what I can say is that the more time you spend doing what I would call inner sense cultivation, the more likely you are to report these events, that people have these moments in which, in effect, what their imagining breaks forth into the world. As she did more research, Tanya realized there was a profound disconnect in the way people think about the imagination today, and the way they used to think about it in earlier times. I think the emphasis on the imagination as something that is obviously
想象力的非常重要的一课。它是一种技能。你可以提高它，让它变得更敏锐，你可以练习它，当你这样做时，非凡的事情就会随之而来。人们体验到各种各样的事情。但我能说的是，你花在进行我所谓的内在感官培养上的时间越多，你报告这些事件的可能性就越大，人们会经历这样一些时刻，在这些时刻中，实际上，他们正在想象的东西爆发到了世界上。随着她进行更多的研究，塔尼娅意识到，今天人们思考想象力的方式与他们早期思考想象力的方式之间存在着深刻的脱节。我认为，将想象力强调为某种明显
not material emerges with the secular world, with the sense that what is real is the stuff that we walk on and the things that we see that everybody else can see, and that what is that everybody else can see, and that what is other is not that real stuff. Tanya went on to become a professor of anthropology at Stanford University. In 2002, she began some new field work focused on another group of people, evangelical Christians who wanted to develop an intense personal relationship with God. They were practicing what she calls, in her sense, cultivation. And I was interviewing some young blonde Southern Californian, who's kind of like her hair would
非物质的东西，是随着世俗世界一起出现的，伴随着这样一种观念：什么是真实的，是我们脚下踩的、我们看到的、所有人都能看到的东西，而什么是所有人都能看到的东西以外的，就不是那些真实的东西。塔尼娅后来成为斯坦福大学人类学教授。2002年，她开始了一项新的田野调查，重点关注另一个群体——渴望与上帝建立强烈个人关系的福音派基督徒。他们在实践她所称的“内在感官培养”。当时我正在采访某个年轻的金发南加州女孩，她的头发总是
swing back and forth. She looked like she belonged to the beach. And I was asking her all these pedantic questions. And at one point, she said, you know, if you want to understand God, just have a cup of coffee with him. Other people told her similar things. The way to make an abstract, invisible entity real in your life was to do things with that entity that you would do with a spouse or a coworker. But I mean, what people would say is that you needed to get to know God the way you would get to know somebody when you went out for coffee with them.
前后摇摆。她看起来就像属于海滩。我问了她一堆迂腐的问题。在某个时候，她说，你知道的，如果你想了解上帝，就跟他喝杯咖啡吧。其他人也对她说过类似的话。在生活中让一个抽象的隐形实体变得真实的方法，就是和那个实体做你会和配偶或同事做的事情。但我的意思是，人们会说的是，你需要去了解上帝，就像你出去喝咖啡时去了解某人一样。
You became a friend of the person. You asked about their life. They asked about your life. You had it back and forth. You learned to know each other. You learned to trust each other. And that that's how you should get to know God. It was like what she had learned in London during the dream sessions, some 20 years earlier. They're using very similar kinds of, what I would call spiritual practices.
你成了那个人的朋友。你询问他们的生活。他们询问你的生活。你们有来有往。你们学会彼此了解。你们学会信任彼此。这就是你应该如何去了解上帝。这就像她大约20年前在伦敦的解梦课程中学到的东西一样。他们在使用非常相似的，我称之为灵性实践的东西。
They were inviting people to use external symbols, props, and internal images, stories, in order to allow the person to enter world which is not the world of the day today and to come to experience that world as if it is present, as if it's real. Tanya met people who said they had practiced these techniques so often that they could interact with God as if God was a living, breathing person. Ever the skeptical scientist, Tanya decided to see if the things she was hearing from evangelical Christians were reproducible in a scientific experiment. She randomly assigned some Christians to practice prayer that involved imagining a very intense personal
他们邀请人们使用外部符号、道具和内部图像、故事，以便让个人进入一个并非日常世界的世界，并开始体验那个世界，就好像它是真实存在的一样，就好像它是真实的一样。塔尼娅遇到了这样的人，他们说他们经常练习这些技术，以至于他们可以与上帝互动，就像上帝是一个活生生的、有呼吸的人一样。作为一名一贯持怀疑态度的科学家，塔尼娅决定看看她从福音派基督徒那里听到的话是否可以在科学实验中重现。她随机指派一些基督徒进行祈祷，要求他们想象与上帝建立非常深厚的个人
relationship with God. She had them read a story from the Bible in which Jesus was represented in different forms, for example as a baby, a shepherd, or on the cross. Then she asked subjects to interact with Jesus in their minds using all of their senses. Sight, sound, smell, touch. Here is an example of one set of instructions related to the Bible's 23rd Psalm, which says, the Lord is my shepherd. See the shepherd before you. See his face, his eyes, the light that streams from him. He turns to walk and
关系。她让他们阅读圣经中的一个故事，其中耶稣以不同的形式出现，例如婴儿、牧羊人或十字架上的形象。然后她要求受试者在脑海中用他们所有的感官与耶稣互动。视觉、听觉、嗅觉、触觉。这里有一个例子，是一组与圣经《诗篇》第23篇相关的指令，该篇写道：耶和华是我的牧者。看到你面前的牧羊人。看到他的脸，他的眼睛，从他身上散发出的光芒。他转身行走，
you follow him. Notice his gate. See the hill over which he leads you. Fill the breeze over the grass. Smell its sweetness. Listen to the birds as they sing. Notice what you feel as you follow this shepherd. Tanya invited the volunteers back after a month. She asked them what had happened in their minds in the intervening weeks. People in the imaginative prayer group responded very differently when people in the control group. So I found that people in the prayer group were more likely to say that their mental images were vivid. There were more likely to say that God felt more like a person to them, that they were more likely to have gotten angry at God or become playful with God.
你跟着他。注意他的步伐。看到他带领你走过的小山。感受草地上的微风。闻到它的香甜。听小鸟歌唱。注意你跟着这位牧羊人时的感受。一个月后，塔尼娅邀请志愿者回来。她问他们在过去的几周里脑海中发生了什么。富有想象力的祈祷组的成员的反应与对照组的成员截然不同。所以，我发现祈祷组的人更有可能说他们的心理图像很生动。他们更有可能说上帝对他们来说更像一个人，他们更有可能对上帝感到生气或对上帝表现得顽皮。
They were also more likely to say that they had a moment when they had heard God speak in a way that could hear with their ears or they had seen something that wasn't materially real in the world, where they'd had some vivid sense of God's presence. There were more likely to say that they'd had an experience as if what had to be experienced in the mind, but somehow broken free and it was experienced with the senses, as if it sort of jumped outside of them,
他们也更有可能说，他们曾有过这样一个时刻：他们听到上帝以一种可以用耳朵听到的方式说话，或者他们看到了世界上物质上并不真实的东西，或者他们对上帝的同在有了某种生动的感官体验。他们更有可能说，他们有过这样一种体验：原本必须在脑海中体验的东西，不知何故打破了束缚，并用感官体验到了它，就好像它跳出了
the mind world barrier and was felt by them in the world. It was like what happened to Megan. The share she imagined in her mind became share. It was share, it was her voice. It was her recognizable share voice. As people consciously exercised our imaginations, the imaginations stopped feeling like imagination. I would ask people whether God was like an imaginary friend, and people would always correct me.
思维与世界的屏障，被他们在世界上感受到了。这就像发生在梅根身上的事一样。她在脑海中想象的雪儿变成了雪儿。那是雪儿，那是她的声音。那是她标志性的雪儿的声音。当人们有意识地锻炼我们的想象力时，想象力就不再像想象了。我会问人们上帝是否像一个想象中的朋友，人们总是会纠正我。
People would say, oh no, he's not imaginary. Then they talk about him as if he was kind of like an invisible being who walked by their side and who, you know, put his arm around their shoulders. People would tell me about sitting next to God on a park bench and they were talking to him about their life and they were asking him about his life. And people, they did that. People told Tanya that they experienced the same curious sensation that Megan experienced with share.
人们会说，哦不，他不是想象出来的。然后他们谈论他，就好像他是一个隐形的人，走在他们身边，你知道的，把胳膊搭在他们的肩膀上。人们会告诉我坐在公园长椅上挨着上帝的经历，他们会跟他谈论他们的生活，也会向他询问他的生活。人们，他们确实这样做了。人们告诉塔尼娅，他们经历了与梅根在雪儿身上经历的同样的奇妙感觉。
The voice of God inside their heads may have sprung from an exercise of the imagination, but it somehow seemed to stand apart from their own minds. It seemed to know more than they did. It seemed to know them better than they knew themselves. It became a source of comfort, of guidance. People would, in effect, take bits and pieces of the best parts of their relationships with other people, and they'd kind of weave them together so that in this what you might almost call play therapy, they are interacting with these different parts of God and then kind of changing their understanding of God
他们脑海中的上帝的声音可能是从想象力的练习中产生的，但它不知何故似乎独立于他们自己的思想之外。它似乎知道得比他们多。它似乎比他们自己更了解他们。它成了安慰和指导的源泉。人们实际上会拿走他们与其他人交往经历中最美好部分的零碎片段，并将它们编织在一起，以便在这个几乎可以称为游戏疗法的过程中，他们与上帝的不同部分进行互动，然后改变他们对上帝的理解，
and then talking about God. And so they're always working on their God concept. What does it look and sound like to work on your God concept? How to believe us distinguish the voice of God from their own hopes and dreams and desires? And what lessons can these imaginings hold for all people, religious and non-religious? When we come back, we go to California to meet one of the evangelical Christians, as the church where Tanya did her field work. We find out how he trains himself to hear the voice of God. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. It's a beautiful morning in Palo Alto, but
然后谈论上帝。所以他们一直在致力于他们的“上帝概念”。致力于你的上帝概念看起来和听起来是什么样的？信徒如何将上帝的声音与他们自己的希望、梦想和渴望区分开来？这些想象力又能给所有人（无论是宗教信徒还是非信徒）带来什么教训？当我们回来时，我们将前往加利福尼亚，去见一位福音派基督徒，就在塔尼娅进行田野调查的那个教堂。我们去了解他是如何训练自己听到上帝的声音的。这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是帕洛阿尔托一个美丽的早晨，
then again, it's always a beautiful morning in Palo Alto. Alex van recent shakes my hand and tells me I remind him of Jennifer Aniston. He doesn't know either of us, but it feels like he does. I found it ironic that you're doing an episode on people that you think you know, but you don't know, and I realize, I'm living that experience this morning by meeting you, Shunker.
话又说回来，帕洛阿尔托总是阳光明媚。亚历克斯·范·里森与我握手，并告诉我我让我想起了詹妮弗·安妮斯顿。他不认识我们俩，但感觉他好像认识。我觉得讽刺的是，你正在做一个关于你以为你认识但其实并不认识的人的一集节目，而我意识到，今天早上通过见到你，尚卡尔，我正在经历这种体验。
Okay. We're meeting at the offices of the Vineyard Church in Palo Alto. Alex used to be a pastor at the church and is now a member. Before we head inside, he pulls from the trunk of his car a black metal box. It has silver hatches and a combination lock. Alex is a big guy, but he strains as he carries the box into the office. He puts it down at his feet and pops the locks. Inside are about 30 carefully numbered, large notebooks.
好的。我们在帕洛阿尔托葡萄园教堂的办公室见面。亚历克斯曾是该教堂的牧师，现在是一名成员。在我们进去之前，他从汽车后备箱里拿出一个黑色金属盒子。它有银色的搭扣和密码锁。亚历克斯是个大块头，但他把盒子搬进办公室时显得很吃力。他把它放在脚边，弹开锁。里面大约有30本仔细编号的大笔记本。
Sort of narrow-ruled. They're like the notebooks you take notes in and almost in a science class. They're very narrow because I write small, and so I have all the journals that I've ever had since 1984. Alex tells me that whenever he's worried or angry or wants to figure out something in his life, he takes out a notebook and asks God, more specifically, Jesus, for guidance. It's what he did after he became lead pastor and was feeling overwhelmed. In small, neat handwriting, Alex carries out a
有点像窄行的那种。它们就像你在科学课上做笔记的笔记本。它们非常窄，因为我写字很小，所以我保存了我自1984年以来用过的所有日记。亚历克斯告诉我，每当他担心、生气或想弄清楚生活中的某件事时，他就会拿出一本笔记本，向上帝（更具体地说是耶稣）寻求指导。这就是他在成为主任牧师并感到不堪重负后所做的事情。亚历克斯用工整秀气的小字进行着
dialogue, a question-enhanced session in which he takes on the role of both himself and Jesus. It's one-part therapy, one-part prayer. He starts with his own side of the conversation. I had a hard time getting up this morning. I wanted to stay in bed. I think I was just starting to feel comfortable in this role as the lead pastor of the church. I feel stirred up, anxious, worried. Jesus asks me, what's another time you felt like this? And I say, well, I'm noting that I've not felt
对话，这是一个问答式的环节，在这个环节中他扮演了自己和耶稣两个角色。这既是一部分心理治疗，又是一部分祈祷。他从对话的自己这一边开始。我今天早上很难起床。我想留在床上。我想我只是开始对教堂主任牧师这个角色感到适应了。我感到心神不宁、焦虑、担忧。耶稣问我，你还有什么时候也有过这种感觉？我说，嗯，我注意到我已经有一段时间没有这种感觉了。我有过这样的时刻，但总的来说，我的生活相当稳定。
like this for a while. I have moments, but in general, my life is pretty solid. That gave me hope that things were really changing for me. Then hearing this news and getting all stirred up internally makes me wonder whether I'm growing at all. Jesus says, I'm at work in you and I'm bringing transformation. You know that I'm about changing people. I have so many questions. Is Alex imagining what Jesus would say? What he thinks he would say? Is he actually hearing a literal voice talking in his ear? Alex says it's not like he just flips a switch and Jesus comes up on his internal radio station.
这给了我希望，事情真的在为我改变。然后听到这个消息，内心一阵翻江倒海，让我怀疑自己到底有没有在成长。耶稣说，我在你里面做工，我正在带来转变。你知道我是为了改变人。我有这么多的问题。亚历克斯是在想象耶稣会说的话吗？他以为耶稣会说的话吗？他真的听到耳边有个直白的说话声音吗？亚历克斯说，这不像是他一拨开关，耶稣就会出现在他内心的广播电台里。
It's a conscious mental practice that is deepened over the years. It's like he imagines what a wise therapist would say, and then he says it to himself. It's similar. I mean, I even, as I'm reading this, and I haven't read this for a while, some of the questions sound like things like, you know, how do you feel about that? A lot of them are questions that Jesus asked me to go deeper with what I'm feeling. But he says there are things that Jesus can tell him that a therapist never could. He can make promises. Promises like, I'm with you. Like, when you feel alone or you feel really trapped, I think that there's promises like,
这是一种有意识的心理练习，多年来一直在深化。这就像他想象一个聪明的治疗师会说的话，然后对自己说出来。这很相似。我的意思是，我甚至，当我读到这个时，我有一段时间没读过这个了，有些问题听起来就像这样，你知道的，你对此有什么感觉？其中很多都是耶稣问我的问题，让我更深入地了解我的感受。但他确实说，有些事情是耶稣能告诉他而治疗师永远做不到的。他可以做出承诺。承诺像，我和你在一起。比如，当你感到孤独或真的陷入困境时，我觉得有这样的承诺，
I have a place for you when you're making a decision and you feel really torn. And you don't know which way to decide and he goes, I will help you. Alex says he was first brought to this way of thinking by a dramatic moment of personal connection with Jesus. And this worship hall, probably like two or three thousand people at this event, and all of a sudden I felt a hand on my shoulder. But I didn't look around, we were in the midst of worship and then very close to my ear, I heard a voice whisper into my ear, things that I had never told anyone. It was a voice, a literal male voice. The voice seemed to now of mean and hurtful things
当我做决定时我有一个地方可以去，而你感到非常纠结。你不知道该做出哪个决定，然后他说，我会帮你的。亚历克斯说，他最初被这种思维方式吸引是因为与耶稣的一次戏剧性的个人连接时刻。在这个礼拜大厅里，这次活动可能大约有两三千人，突然之间我感觉到一只手搭在我的肩膀上。但我没有环顾四周，我们正处于敬拜之中，然后离我的耳朵非常近的地方，我听到一个声音在我耳边低语，说了一些我从未告诉过任何人的事情。那是一个声音，一个直白的男性的声音。这个声音似乎知道一些卑鄙和伤人的事情，
that Alex had done to other people. I was like, how could somebody know these things? I think you also mentioned that I know that your life has been hard. I know it's pains you that your mother died at childbirth. That you didn't have a close relationship with your biological siblings, and he said, I know these things, and I love you, and I'm with you. And so the minute he stopped speaking, he turned around, and there was no one there. Alex used an analogy to describe what his conversations with Jesus were like.
那是亚历克斯对其他人做过的事。我就想，怎么会有人知道这些事情？我想你也提到过，我知道你的生活很艰难。我知道你母亲在生育时去世让你感到痛苦。你与你的亲生兄弟姐妹没有密切的关系，他说，我知道这些事情，我爱你，我和你在一起。所以在他停止说话的那一刻，我转过身去，那里空无一人。亚历克斯用了一个类比来描述他与耶稣的对话是什么样的。
It sounded curiously to me like the language Tanya Lurman used to describe what anthropologists do. It had to do with the power of slowing down, listening attentively, and then finding yourself seeing things, noticing things that you might have missed. The analogy I like to use is the difference between driving to your home and walking to your home or riding a bicycle and all the things that you see in your neighborhood when you walk that you don't see when you drive because you're going so fast. And I think that a lot of what we're trying to do in our service and in really our
在我听来，这奇怪地类似于塔尼娅·勒曼用来描述人类学家所做事情的语言。这与放慢速度、专注聆听的力量有关，然后你会发现自己看到了事物，注意到了那些你可能错过的事物。我喜欢用的类比是，开车回家和步行回家，或者骑自行车回家的区别，你在步行时看到的社区里的所有东西，你在开车时是看不到的，因为你开得太快了。我认为我们在我们的礼拜中，以及真正地在我们的
lives is to create space that for God to speak because we believe He's speaking, we believe He's present, but we just don't create the space. And when we create the space, most times, but not always, He'll say something. So how does Alex tell the voice of Jesus from his own voice? He told me that members of the church regularly listen to each other's accounts of what Jesus told them. They'll tell each other, yeah, that sounds like Jesus. Or they'll say, no, that doesn't sound right. Alex invited me to listen in on one of these group sessions. We got in his car to go meet a couple of other church members.
生活就是为上帝说话创造空间，因为我们相信祂在说话，我们相信祂就在现场，但我们只是没有创造空间。当我们创造了空间，大多数时候，但并非总是，祂会说些什么。那么，亚历克斯是如何分辨出耶稣的声音和自己的声音的呢？他告诉我，教会成员经常倾听彼此关于耶稣对他们说了什么的叙述。他们会告诉对方，是的，这听起来像耶稣。或者他们会说，不，这听起来不太对。亚历克斯邀请我旁听其中一次小组讨论。我们上了他的车，去见其他几位教会成员。
So we pick up some food on the way. What are we doing about that? How hungry are you? Where are you at? I'm actually on the... As we drove, Alex told me that the voice of Jesus had helped him during one of the most traumatic moments in his life. In the late 1990s, Alex and his wife Susan were trying to have children.
所以在路上我们买了一些吃的。我们打算怎么处理那个？你有多饿？你现在在哪里？我其实在……在开车的过程中，亚历克斯告诉我，在他人生中最痛苦的时刻之一，耶稣的声音曾帮助过他。在20世纪90年代末，亚历克斯和他的妻子苏珊正试图要孩子。
They had trouble conceiving, so they looked into adoption. Eventually, they learned about a beautiful baby boy, just two days old. The baby seemed healthy and happy. They brought him home and named him Joshua. But ten days later, baby Joshua started to lose weight, and it became clear that something was very wrong. Alex and Susan took him to the emergency room and then to the intensive care unit. After 17 terrifying days, our doctor told Alex and Susan the news.
他们怀孕困难，于是考虑领养。最终，他们了解到了一个美丽的男婴，刚出生两天。这个婴儿看起来健康而快乐。他们把他带回家，给他起名叫约书亚。但十天后，小约书亚开始体重减轻，情况显然非常不对劲。亚历克斯和苏珊把他送到急诊室，然后又送到重症监护室。在经历了17天惊心动魄的日子后，我们的医生将这个消息告诉了亚历克斯和苏珊。
Their son had a rare disease that might leave him severely disabled. She said that he might never live an independent life. She sat down and she went, he could be completely blind, he could have cerebral palsy, he could have very little brain function, he could have no mobility, no ability to speak, no, and he, she just kept going and going and going. And it was just like, you know, everything in the kitchen sink. I just remember feeling utterly devastated, meaning I was just so, so sad. There was an overwhelming sense of what have we gotten ourselves into, like, will I have what it takes to really go the distance with this. Alex thought back to an adoption contract they had signed.
他们的儿子患有一种罕见的疾病，可能会导致他严重残疾。她说，他可能永远无法过上独立的生活。她坐下来，然后说道，他可能会完全失明，他可能会患有脑瘫，他的大脑功能可能非常低下，他可能没有行动能力，没有说话的能力，不，她就一直说下去，说个没完。这就好像，你知道的，把厨房水槽里能端出来的东西全端出来了。我只记得当时感到彻底的崩溃，这意味着我真的是伤心欲绝。有一种铺天盖地的感觉，那就是我们到底卷入了什么，比如，我是否有能力真正与这个孩子携手走过这段漫长的旅程。亚历克斯回想起他们签署的一份收养合同。
It left room for the parents to change their minds. Alex was 39 years old and his life already felt so full. He had a job in campus ministry which took up more than 50 hours a week. A disabled child felt like more than he could handle. He told Susan about his feelings. She told him, if Josh had come to us through biological means, if we had had a special needs baby biologically, there's nowhere to take that baby back to, right? In other words, no one comes to you and goes, we'll take your baby back. And I think she was like, this is, there's no returning here. God was in this and, and he has a purpose for this. A few nights after that conversation,
合同留出了让父母改变主意的余地。亚历克斯39岁了，他的生活已经感觉非常充实。他在校园事工有一份工作，每周占用超过50个小时。一个残疾儿童让他觉得难以应付。他把自己的感受告诉了苏珊。她告诉他，如果乔舒亚是通过生物学途径来到我们身边的，如果我们从生物学角度生了一个有特殊需求的婴儿，那是没有地方可以把这个婴儿退回去的，对吧？换句话说，没有人会来找你并说，我们会把你的婴儿带回。我想她的意思是，这是，这里没有退路。上帝参与其中，而且，祂对此有目的。那次对话之后的几个晚上，
Alex went out to a park near their home. He looked up at the sky, searching for answers. And I sat on a bench and I said, look, this scares the living daylights out of me. I don't know, are we supposed to give him back? Do you want us to keep him? And I was just looking at the stars. And all of a sudden, it was one of those senses. I didn't hear an audible voice outside
亚历克斯走到他们家附近的一个公园里。他抬头看着天空，寻找答案。我坐在长椅上，我说，听着，这把我吓得魂不附体。我不知道，我们是不是应该把他送回去？你希望我们留着他吗？我当时只是看着星星。突然之间，我有一种感觉。我没有听到外界有清晰的声音
my head, but I heard very clearly, you know, I bring children into people's lives all sorts of ways. This is the way I brought Joshua into yours. And so, like that, I was like, okay, I'm in. And I haven't doubted it since. So this is Susan's mother's place? Yeah! Okay, got it. Yep. Where in Alex's mother-in-law's condo, two other members of the Vineia Church show up soon after.
在我脑海里，但我听得很清楚，你知道的，我以各种方式将孩子带入人们的生活。这就是我将约书亚带进你生活的方式。就这样，我想，好吧，我加入。从那以后我再也没有怀疑过。所以这是苏珊母亲的家？对！好吧，明白了。是的。在亚历克斯岳母的公寓里，维尼亚教会的其他两位成员不久后出现了。
My name is Terence Magno. I am a software engineer. My name is Suzanne Magno. And I am the Director of Worship and Administration at Kaua Alto Vignia Church. And I'm married to Terence. They explained to me what a group prayer session looks like. It's called a soaking prayer because everyone in attendance is set to be soaked in God's presence.
我叫特伦斯·马格诺。我是一名软件工程师。我叫苏珊·马格诺。我是阿尔托维尼亚教会的敬拜与行政总监。我嫁给了特伦斯。他们向我解释了小组祈祷会是什么样子的。这被称为浸泡式祈祷，因为在场的每个人都将沉浸在上帝的同在中。
The person they are praying for, the prayee, and the prayers, all try to channel what Jesus might say. By inviting Jesus into their minds, they hope to make him vivid, to make him a participant in the conversation. By deliberately exercising their imaginations, by suspending disbelief, they hope to make the invisible real. When I first started to pray in this way, it was difficult to discern, is this my imagination? Or did God give me this?
他们为之祈祷的人，即祈祷对象，以及祈祷者，都试图引导耶稣可能会说的话。通过邀请耶稣进入他们的脑海，他们希望使祂变得生动，使祂成为对话的参与者。通过刻意锻炼他们的想象力，通过暂停不信任，他们希望将无形变为现实。当我第一次开始以这种方式祈祷时，很难辨别，这到底是我的想象？还是上帝给我的？
And I'll be honest, like I still doubt. We gather together in a quiet room. The lights are low. Alex pulls up chairs from the dining table. He straddles a chair sitting backwards. His arms crossed on the backrest. Terence and Suzanne face him so that the three of them are sitting in a triangle. So God, we just invite your Holy Spirit to come. So come, Holy Spirit. Terence asks Alex what he wants to talk about.
老实说，我还是会怀疑。我们聚集在一个安静的房间里。灯光很暗。亚历克斯把餐桌旁的椅子拉了过来。他跨坐在一把椅子上，反着坐。他的手臂交叉在靠背上。特伦斯和苏珊面对着他，他们三个人呈三角形坐着。上帝啊，我们邀请你的圣灵降临。来吧，圣灵。特伦斯问亚历克斯想聊些什么。
Alex says a friend that he calls Steve has wronged him and he's not sure how to let it go. I don't want good for him." Suzanne and Terence ask Alex if it's okay for each of them to place a hand on his shoulder. Alex says yes. His head is resting on his forearms. His eyes are closed. I suppose you give that to Alex. What's Ernie? Anything arising? Anything new arising from that?
亚历克斯说，一个他称之为史蒂夫的朋友冤枉了他，他不知道该如何释怀。我不想为他好。苏珊和特伦斯问亚历克斯，他们每个人把一只手放在他的肩膀上是否可以。亚历克斯说可以。他的头靠在前臂上。他的眼睛闭着。我想你把那个交给亚历克斯。厄尼是什么？有什么出现的吗？有什么由此产生的新东西吗？
You're feeling? I think I was more just sitting in now. anything new or rising from that, you're feeling? I think I was more just sitting in now. Struck I was that what I wanted was, to build up anger and frustration at this person. And I'm just struck by that. So I think I'm kinda sitting in that, I don't know, I'm just struck by that. So I think I'm kind of sitting in that, I don't know realization. Suzanne says she sees something.
你的感觉？我想我更多地只是坐在现在。有什么新的或由此产生的东西，你的感觉？我想我更多地只是坐在现在。我感到震惊的是，我想要的是，对这个人建立愤怒和沮丧。我对此感到震惊。所以我认为我有点坐在那里面，我不知道，我只是对那个感到震惊。所以我认为我有点坐在那里面，我不知道这种顿悟。苏珊说她看到了什么。
I saw you at a tree stump that has already been cut, right? It's just a stump and you had an axe and you're angry and you're like raising your fists at God in the sky. And you're like, why do I have to be here? I keep, you know, you're tired. You just keep hacking at this, with this axe, and you're just tired, and you don't want to be there, but somehow you're there. Titan says he can see something too.
我看到你站在一个已经被砍断的树桩旁，对吧？它只是一个树桩，你拿着一把斧子，你很生气，就像在空中向天上的上帝挥舞着拳头。你好像在说，我为什么要在这里？我一直，你知道的，你累了。你只是一直在用这把斧子砍这个东西，你只是累了，你不想呆在那里，但不知何故你就在那里。泰坦说他也能看到一些东西。
There's just this picture I'm getting of, sort of you are seated in like a front porch or a stoop of an apartment building or a house, and Jesus is sort of sitting next to you and has his hand over your heart, but the interesting thing about the picture is that his heart is broken Alex takes in what Terence and Suzanne have told him the metaphor of the porch doesn't spark anything inside him
我脑海里浮现出这样一幅画面，你坐在公寓楼或房子的前廊或门廊上，耶稣就坐在你旁边，把手放在你的心上，但画面有趣的地方在于，他的心碎了亚历克斯接受了特伦斯和苏珊告诉他的话，门廊的比喻并没有在他内心激起任何火花
But Suzanne's image does Alex runs with it. He says he sees Jesus enter the picture. I see him standing there next to me while I'm whacking away at the stump. He's standing there, you know, he's relaxed. And I just keep going ahead and I ask him, Jesus, is there something you want to say or you want me to do He sits down. He's kind of cross-legged He sits down and goes do you want me to take over and I'm not sure. Because I don't know what taking over means from him. But I'll say yes. Yes, Jesus, I'm a little worried or afraid about that. Go ahead. I'll let you take over.
但苏珊的意象做到了。亚历克斯顺着这个思路想下去了。他说他看到耶稣进入了画面。我看到他站在我旁边，而我在猛砍树桩。他站在那里，你知道的，他很放松。我继续前进，我问他，耶稣，有什么你想说的或者你想让我做的吗？他坐下来。他有点盘腿坐着。他坐下来，说道，你想让我接管吗？我不太确定。因为我不知道他接管意味着什么。但我会说是的。是的，耶稣，我对此有点担心或害怕。继续吧。我让你接管。
Yeah. Thank you, Lord. So I hand him the axe and he puts it down. In fact, to me, to sit down next to him. Yes, Lord. Give me a breath in particular, you say? Well, I think he says, this isn't for you to carry. When the soaking prayer is over, Alex genuinely seems to be at peace. I ask Terence and Suzanne how the comfort they have given Alex is different than the comfort that a friend or a psychotherapist might offer.
好的。谢谢你，主。所以我把斧子递给他，他把它放下了。事实上，对我来说，坐在他旁边。是的，主。特别给我一口气，你说？嗯，我想他说，这不是让你来背负的。当浸泡式祈祷结束时，亚历克斯看起来真的很平静。我问特伦斯和苏珊，他们给予亚历克斯的安慰与朋友或心理治疗师可能提供的安慰有什么不同。
I think this is a very therapeutically similar technique, but I think if it weren't for the voice of God, I would not have received the tree trunk image. I mean, yeah, I did see something like that in a movie but I think God used that picture said here this applies right and so I think when you add God into the picture there's a knowing of the person's life and inner workings that as a friend we may not know. So I think for us to invite God to speak into Alex's problem is kind of like a really great prescription. It's like the perfect prescription that could be given to someone who's in pain.
我认为这是一种在治疗上非常相似的技术，但我想如果没有上帝的声音，我是不会收到树干图像的。我的意思是，是的，我在电影里确实看到过这样的东西，但我想上帝使用了那个画面说，看，这适用，对吧，所以我想当你把上帝加入到画面中时，你会对这个人的生活和内心运作有一种了解，作为朋友我们可能并不了解。所以我认为我们邀请上帝对亚历克斯的问题发表意见，有点像一个非常棒的处方。这就像可以给一个处于痛苦中的人的完美处方。
2. Too often, religious and non-religious people get hung up on questions of what is real. Did Jesus actually speak to Suzanne? Did he actually tell Alex to put down the axe? Or did Alex imagine it? Now, there are times when questions like, is this real and did this actually happen, are useful. If God tells you to go kill someone, it's worth asking if God is actually doing the talking. But when you are looking for a way to put down a long-held grudge or suffering from a
2. 通常，宗教和非宗教人士都会纠结于什么是真实的问题。耶稣真的对苏珊说话了吗？他真的告诉亚历克斯放下斧子了吗？还是亚历克斯想象出来的？现在，有时像“这是真的吗”以及“这真的发生了吗”这样的问题是有用的。如果上帝告诉你去杀人，那确实值得怀疑上帝是否真的在说话。但是，当你寻找一种放下长期积怨的方法时，或者遭受着
cute shame because you can't read, it seems silly to question the comfort offered by the voices in our heads. For some of us, those voices can be religious. For others, they can be the voice of a beloved TV character or a close relative who has died. The human capacity for imagination is one of the greatest gifts of the brain. Our imaginings can certainly lead us astray, cause us to see things we wish to see instead of seeing reality for what it is. Those concerns are well-founded, but they should not lead to a narrow absolutism. Sometimes amazing things can happen when we allow ourselves to listen
由于你不识字而带来的剧烈羞耻感，质疑我们脑海中声音所提供的安慰似乎很愚蠢。对我们中的一些人来说，这些声音可能是宗教的。对其他人来说，它们可能是心爱的电视角色的声音，或者是死去的近亲的声音。人类的想象力是大脑最伟大的天赋之一。我们的想象力当然会把我们带入歧途，让我们看到我们希望看到的东西，而不是看到事物的本来面目。这些担忧是有根据的，但它们不应导致狭隘的绝对主义。有时，当我们允许自己倾听时，神奇的事情就会发生
allow ourselves to listen to our secret friends. This week's show was produced by Laura Correll and Pat Shah, and edited by Tara Boyle and Jenny Schmidt. Our team includes Thomas Liu, Raina Cohen and Lu Sheik Waba. A special thanks this week to all the voice actors in our show, Kevin Beasley, Jason Fuller. Our Ransung Hero this week is Stacey Goers. She is the senior product manager for podcasts at NPR and she is the go-to person for putting out fires and solving all kinds of problems.
允许自己倾听我们秘密朋友的声音。本周的节目由劳拉·科雷尔（Laura Correll）和帕特·沙阿（Pat Shah）制作，由塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）和珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）剪辑。我们的团队包括托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）、雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）和卢·谢克·瓦巴（Lu Sheik Waba）。本周我们要特别感谢节目中的所有配音演员，凯文·比斯利（Kevin Beasley）、杰森·富尔拉（Jason Fuller）。我们本周的无名英雄是斯黛西·戈尔斯（Stacey Goers）。她是NPR播客的高级产品经理，也是解决各种火情和各种问题的首选人物。
Without her, our show might not reach your ears. Thank you, Stacy. For more Hidden Brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. If this episode spoke to you, please share it with a friend. Finally, if you have a parasocial relationship with me, why not come and meet me in person? Get a selfie. A hidden brain live event will be held in Boston on Sunday, March 15th.
没有她，我们的节目可能无法传到你的耳中。谢谢你，斯黛西。有关更多《隐秘的大脑》（Hidden Brain），您可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。如果这一集对你有所触动，请与朋友分享。最后，如果你和我有一种准社会关系，为什么不亲自来见我呢？拍张自拍照。Hidden Brain现场活动将于3月15日星期日在波士顿举行。
Details and ticketing information can be found at events.hiddenbrain.org. Again, that's events.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantum and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
详细信息和购票信息可在 events.hiddenbrain.org 上找到。再说一次，那是 events.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。你本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。